Tyler Cameron is standing by gigi hadid
side through good times and bad the 26
year old Bachelorette alum was spotted
in the Netherlands on Wednesday where he
attended the funeral of his rumoured
girlfriend's grandmother who died in
August after a battle with cancer
Gigi's sister Bella and brother Anwar
were also in attendance for the sad
occasion as well as an Mars girlfriend
duo Lipa on the way inside Tyler was
photographed with his arm around the 24
year old model and if you look closely
you can see she has her arm around his
waist
Gigi shared this pic from inside the
service where she and Bella along with
their cousin lovingly placed their hands
on their grandmothers flower covered
casket that same day the Bachelorette
runner up set the record straight on a
fans claim that he shaded Hannah brown
with a like' on social media luckily
just don't go away in a series of tweets
Tyler called the so called shade a
complete accident and told his followers
that Hannah deserves nothing but success
and praised her for starting important
conversations about and for women she
empowers women and deserves all the
accolades sweet right well he didn't
stop there Tyler added I am grateful for
our time together and all that I learned
from her he wrapped up writing way too
grateful for any shade in my life all
love on my end
have you talked to Tyler yes just hours
earlier Hannah opened up to et about
their most recent chat I sent him a
message when his dad was sick but not
nothing else relationship II anything
you would want to say
fans have been keeping an eagle eye on
Hannah and Tyler since she asked him out
for a drink on the season finale of The
Bachelorette in July I don't know I just
thought maybe we could go for a drink
and just pay it I would love to just
tell me one on that he spent the night
at her place in LA soon after that we
definitely hung out and talked about
everything but days later he was spotted
with Gigi you know I think where we were
both single and it is his decision to do
whatever makes him happy and so I want
my own happiness I'm moving forward
[Music]
[Applause]